FM TV Rahim Cortial grand Rabin de
France et Chems Edine affiz le reeur de
la Grande Mosquée de Paris ont voulu
lancer un appel à la paix c'est un beau
moment ça sur BFM regarde je veux
aujourd'hui un qu'on n'importe pas ce
conflit moi je veux que raahim reste mon
frère à jamais et tous les Juifs de
France et les musulmans de France on
doit vivre de la sorte et leur colère
leur tristesse nous la partageons à ce
moment-là il faut pas aujourd'hui que
nous puissions nous religion faire un
distingo ce que certains hommes
politiques font moi je considère que
chaque âme que nous perdons que chaque
personne qui meurt moi je vais vous dire
une chose Monsieur j'attends aujourd'hui
les otages et j'espère que le Président
de la République puisse qu'il est là on
va avoir le retour des aotates pour que
mes frères j
soure excuse-moi j'adore BR tout ça
c'est insupportable comment il le coup
laiss finir
le recevoir la semaine prochaines cor
vraiment ça
ser il est extraordinaire voilà il
extraordinaire il a tout dit et voilà et
quand il a dit j'aimerais queim reste
mon frère et c'est vrai que voilà ils
sont très très proches j'aimerais
beaucoup les avoir la semaine prochaine
c'est un voilà de garçons qui sont
formidables les deux et vraiment ça ça c
c'est un bon moment mais couper c'est
insupportable oui la semaine dernière je
disais voilà pourquoi c'est important
d'avoir un représentant alors ça a été
mal compris mais c'est pas forcément un
représentant qui représente tout le
monde mais je veux dire en tous les cas
des voix comme ça qui compent qui
portent parce que ben on s'y réfère et
parce que c'est structurant pour la
société parce que c'est évidemment des
messages de paix et on a tous envie
évidemment de que la paix puisse
s'installer et que israélien et est
validé lui parce que la dernière fois
j'avais cité un il m'avait dit qu'il
était pas validé cétait Monsieur Charles
Goumi vous aviez qui lui n'est pas du
tout validé et donc lui est validé
extrêmement validé d'accord si c'est
votre question je réponds franchement
c'est monsieur chalgoui qui pose
problème on a déjà par que Monsieur
chalgi actu ement il n'est plus en
France parce qu'il a été menacé ces
dernières heures non mais je ne ve j'ai
jamaistimé les menaces j'apporte un
élément d' là vous faites un procès
d'intention mon cher cardose là je n'ai
jamais validé les menaces et je suis
pour la protection absolue de Monsieur
chalgoumi je dis simplement qu'il n'est
pas une voix qui représente les
musulmans de France il n jamais été
j'ajoute au débat que malheureusement il
a dû quitter la France ces dernières
heures parce qu'il est menacé il apporte
une info il apporte une info c'est
extrêmement malheureux effectivement
mais je voulais avoir cette info pour
pour ce non pour savoir justement si
justement il était pas à la solde du
pouvoir de darin comme mais c'est que
mon avis hein c'est uniquement mon avis
he voà c'est mieux que moi moi je sais
pas donc en tout cas on espère la voir
la semaine prochaine ave PL merci merci
fait merci c'est bon hier la Une de
Charlie Hebdo a fait énormément réagir
ils ont décidé de se moquer de
laanupesse et de leur prise de position
en particulier Jean-Luc Mélenchon
regardez ça a fait énormément parler
cette uneune laanupess une prison à ciel
ouvert sortez-nous de là qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez c'est l'humour Charli ah
ouais c'est Charli bah oui c'est du
Charlie moi jeis c'est plutôt drôle mais
bon j'ai rie ah oui j'ai bah ça se
voit maintenant non parce qu' lui il
j'ai r j'ai r Oui j'ai mais ça m'a fait
rire donc je vais pas dire maintenant
est qu' y en a qui qui aiment pas non
moi j'aime non voilà très bien merci
vous avez vu que l'influenceuse May
vagenham qui s'est exprimé plusieurs
fois en soutien au Palestiniens face à
la ripos de l'armée israélienne a décidé
de rompre son contrat avec Magalie Berda
alors que puisque l'agente d'influenceur
rappelle régulièrement son soutien aux
Israéliens depuis les attaque terroriste
du Hamas est-ce que vous voulez réagir
là-dessus est-ce que quelqu'un peut
réagir ou quelqu'un oui c'est vous
placer he c'est non mais c'est triste en
fait quand le conflit a des
répercussions c'est pas extrêmement
grave il y a pas il y a pas mort d'homme
évidemment et quand ça a des
répercussions dans les relations entre
les gens dans des milieux qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec les milieux
politique dans un pays comme la France
je trouve ça déplorable et je pense que
c'est à l'image de plein de gens qui
malheureusement se sont peut-être
engueulés éloignés suite à ce ce conflit
parce qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord et je
trouve que voilà au lieu de se diviser
on devrait tous se réunir et au moins
être d'accord pour la paix et là c'est
c'est c'est d'une tristess absolu je
trouvesolum vous trouvez oui oui g je
suis pas d'accord encore une fois et je
prends pas partie du tout entre les deux
personnes mais quand on fait
passer sa morale ses convictions avant
un contrat économique parce que là on se
sent profondément proche du mouvement
palestinien je trouve que c'est
honorable on estime qu'on ne peut plus
travailler dans une certaine condition
on le dit et on rond moi je trouve que
c'est honorable pas d'accord c'est un
vrai débat non c'est pas parce qu'on pas
d'accord avec quelqu'un qu'on doit plus
fréquenter plus lui parler plus lu
bonjour au contraire devrait être amis
et proche des gens y compris ceux qui ne
pensent pas la même chose que nous sinon
tout le monde va se divisé Gill c'est
c'est la fin de la société là c'est ell
ront un contrat elles sont amis aussi en
quoi elle est en désaccord sur le ce
qu'a dit Magali qui en l'occurrence est
de dire que le ramas a fait du
terrorismes et a tué des femmes et des
enfants en quoi ça peut heurter les
convictions de Maeva Guam elle ne dit
pas je suis contre le peuple palestinien
en tout cas
je n'ai pas vu en tout cas Magal Berda
dire ça donc je comprends pas ce en quoi
ça pourrait la heurter de dire ce qu'a
fait le ramas le 7 octobre c'est un acte
de terrorisme c'est de la barbarie je
dis pas que je suis d'accord avec
maaagam ce qu'elle dit je dis que je
suis d'accord avec ce qu'elle fait si on
se sent
désaccordou comprend rien en fait ce que
vous dites excusez-moi je
pas à chaque fois maintenant c'est du
ton
truc le conflit entre Israël et la
Palestine ne date pas de de il y a jours
3 semaines donc à ce qu' ne
si elle avait si la moralité passa avant
les contrats fallait qu'elle ne signe
jamais avec Magali à ce pointl et sans
mépriser personne sans mépriser personne
parce que nous non plus on n'est pas des
spécialistes je pense que ni l'une ni
l'autre sont des spécialistes du conflit
donc on peut pas
s'empêcher on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
de de penser à des clichés qui sont r
mais en fait ça on en vient à les juifs
contre les musulmans parce que Magalie
Berda est juif parce queaganem est
musulmane et ça ça cré les tension éneré
non je pas énervé mais c'est pas dit
c'est pas d'h hier que Magali BDA est
juive et c'est pas d'hier queam est
musulmane donc pourquoi il il s'énerv
maintenant là en ce moment on n'arrête
pas de voir des gens qui ouais faut
t'engager pour la Palestine faut
t'engager bien sûr qu'on est engagé
depuis la Palestine d'un conflit de 70
ans bien sûr qu'on veut que ça s'arrête
moi je suis content quand je vois un
imam et et et quand je vois un rabin sur
sur sur un plateau de télé prenez la
paix bien sûr je je suis heureux mais je
veux plus je veux qu'on règle ce conflit
et qu'on arrête d'envoyer des bombes et
qu'on arrête d'avoir des attentats du
Hamas que les gens disent bien que le
Hamas c'est une organisation tion
terroriste il y a pas à transiger
là-dessus c'est clair net et précis et
qu'on dise aussi maintenant on arrête
les bombardements mais de voir Magali
Berda et druc ils ont pris de l' pendant
des années ensemble et il se réveill un
matin ah il y a la guerre en Palestine
ah il y a des bombes en Palestine mais
les mecs il y a la guerre en Ukraine il
y a la guerre partout dans le monde ça
vous fait rien du tout et là on fait
Palestine Palestine Palestine alors
évidemment viens on arrête le conflit
viens on arrête ce de conflit et
on arrête de dire oui on va faire la
paix oui peut-être qu'on fera la paix on
va mettre un imam un rabin sur un
plateau et on va discuter non c'est bon
et l'autre ils nous font leur cinéma là
je on se parle plus mais guellarda elle
est juif depuis combien de temps tu
faisais de l'oseille avec elle avant ça
te dérangeait pas et là maintenant ça te
dérange et on voit des messages de
partout Palestine Palestine oui on
soutient la Palestine et c'est pas
négociable et on veut pas que les
Palestiniens les civils se fassent
bombarder gratuitement 2 millions de
gens à qui ont dit sauvez-vous on sauvez
où on est pas con ils vont pas se sauver
et même ils ne veulent pas se sauver ils
veulent rester en Palestine ils ne
veulent pas se sauver que ce soit clair
moi les trucs comme ça ça me fait rire
et ça m'énerve c'est des chiffons ça
pour moi pour moi c'est des chiffonniers
ça ça c'est n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi et puis par ailleurs
maagam je sais pas si je la connais pas
cette jeune fille mais elle était il y a
quelques temps au mariage en cet été au
mariage de magberda où ça en Israël et
là le sort des Palestiniens à ce momentl
il y avait le conflit d'intérêt il
existait pas ou il existait donc je
comprends pas cette positionition là
maintenant guerriers des
révolutionnaires on a eu le covid ils
ont tous' acheté du PCU ils sont fermé
chez eux ils ont acheté de l'huile
d'olive et de la moutarde et ça jou les
révolutionnaires me saz pas de quoi vous
parle moi je sais pas de quoi je parle
moi tu peux m'accuser
non tu peux m'accuser d'un truc qui est
grave tu peux dire oui tu soutiens pas
machin ceci cela tu peux m'accuser d'un
truc mais moi j'ai pas attendu
aujourd'hui pour savoir qu'il y avait
des problèmes dans le monde j'ai pas
entendu aujourd'hui pour savoir qu'il y
avait un conflit je vous l'ai dit
l'autre fois je me suis réveillé toute
ma vie avec un conflit Israël Palestine
et aujourd'hui tu as des mecs qui
t'envoient des messages ouais tu sais ce
que c'est la guerre toi mais tu sais ce
que c'est toi la guerre espèce de pauvre
con va tu es rester enfermé chez toi
avec du PQ qu'est-ce que tu viens me
parler de guerre arrêtez il faut régler
ça en fait on peut en parler sur les
plateaux de télé partout on peut inviter
des gens on peut prener la paix mais ça
fait ça va durer combien de temps on se
autour d'une table et les mecs les
dirigeants politiques et on règle ça
pour de vrai on arrête de faire
semblant regarde quand je vois ça là je
me dis mais c'est on est pas sorti de la
merde oui Jacques qu'est-ce que tu pens
tu penses de ce que non mais que je
voulais je suis assez choqué par ce que
tu dis Gilles parce que c'estent choé
par que ouais mais non jeessaie de le
dire calmement mais c'est placer cette
morale dans ta vie privée aujourd'hui
dans tes affaires et
cetera on peut évidemment avoir des
convictions ça n'empêche pas d'être
contre la personne qui est à côté de toi
et de et d'essayer au contraire de des
liens d'avoir une contradiction pour moi
c'est ça la vie je veux dire je suis pas
forcément d'accord avec tous les gens
qui sont là autour de moi mais mais je
je je je j'adore le fait de pouvoir
échanger argumenter et et c'est ça qui
fait que on se nourrit tous des uns et
des autres j'adore cette phrase qui est
il faut savoir penser contre soi-même et
ça c'est exactement le contraire on se
sépare parce que en fait on s'aperçoit
qu'on appartient à deux mondes et ça je
trouve ça terrible je trouve que c'est
un échec C c'est terrible parce qu'elles
ont elles se connaissent en plus voilà
je savais pas qu'elles étaient au
mariage l'une de l'autre enfin je veux
dire bon elle travaill ensemble ouais
enfin tu vois voilà et je trouve que
cette logique qui consiste à vouloir se
séparer alors qu'on n pas d'accord non
on n'est pas d'accord mais on en parle
on boit un café on se met et puis on
décide qu'on parle plus de politique et
puis on continue tu vois enfin je sais
pas ou un
diaboloout quand on essaie d'analyser le
point de rupture entre les deux c'est
quoi le point de rupture en fait
qu'est-ce qui fait que Maeva décide de
quitter et de rompre un contrat avec
avec Magali c'est quoi ton avis c'est
tout simplement qu'elle pouroi parce il
y en a une qui est juive et l'autre qui
est musulmane tu vois bien
c'est les que j'avais parlé les de c'est
le traitement médiatique de ce conflit
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'elles éman des réseaux sociaux qui
réduisent ce conflit à mettre un drap
israélien ou mettre un drapeau
palestinen même le silence es dans un
bord aussi et quand tu es pour la pai tu
es dans un B auss l ne vous méprenez pas
je pense qu'il n'y a eu aucune
discussion sur le fond du conflit entre
ces deux femmes je pense que ça se
résume à un drapeau palestinien un
drapeau israélien on a pas le même
drapeau on est plus pot tu sais
Guillaume c'est comme politique qu'on a
en famille il se peut très bien dans une
famille qu'on soit absolument pas
d'accord ça empêche pas que ENF je veux
dire j'espère qu'on continue à se voir
on se parle on en le pine du chef il est
pas d'accord avec ce qu'on dit et
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi c'est quoi
leur point de rupture
en oui voilà alors c'est quoi qu'est-ce
qui a fait que MAA s dit je ne peux plus
travailler c'est quoi la raison c'est le
Dra Guillaume l'a dit mais encore une
fois vous avez les bons arguments et
vous n'arrivez pas à conclure je vais le
faire à votre place en fait vous avez le
drapeau palestinien et le drapeau
israélien mais c'est la réalité des RA
c'est la réalité d'un phénomène qui est
extrêmement sur les réseaux en sont
lesation l'une dit je défends la
Palestine l'autre dit je défend Israël
et c'est la
rupture cette rupture qui fait que des
gens qui étai comme des frères avant et
du coup du jour lendemain pour conflit
qui n'a fait que s'exorciser aujourd'hui
décide de plus
parlerac exacerb excuse-moi et ben du
coup décide de ne plus parler comme ça
tu connes ça et ton
courage moi je l'aurais pas
faitexlique ce qu'elle fait mais je vous
dis honnêtement je la comprends elle ma
Eva com si c'est valeurs sont supérieurs
à
Berda avait dit je ne veux plus
travailler avecam dans l'autre sens
parce que tu as mis un drapeau
palestinien et moi ça ne me va pas
est-ce que tu aurais aussi compris mais
bien sûr mais moi je comprends qu'il
puisse y avoir un clage tel qu'il y ait
une
rupture contire
de ça existe elles l'ont fait j'essae de
dire elle l'a fait je
comprends
reemain des attent jeux pasor France
malheureusement il a des attentats et
c'est dramatique mais là il s'importe
dans la vie de tous les jours entre des
gens qui sont amis collègues de travail
et qui se déchirent à cause de ce confit
et toi tu supportes ça tu l'encourages
c'est lamentable pas propager la
haine la question je pose la
question P ce que tu dis un facteur de
division je par de division mais c'est
un facteur de division les gens sontés
c'est choisir un camp tu peux pas dire
le contraire on oblige c'est ce que
j'avais dit ici quand au lendemain que
c'est arrivé tu nous as dit là toi tu as
dit tu avais parlé tu avais dit d'abord
on y connait rien et on se rend compte
tous les jours qu'on y connaît rien et
que tu te réveilles le matin avec des
gens qui s'aperço ah ça existe la
Palestine il y a 3 jours ils étaient en
boîte de nuit à boire du champagne à
faire n'importe quoi à faire les
dingueries du monde entier et là
maintenant ensemble il faisaent la fête
ensemble et il se réveill le matin il
découvre la Palestine et là il dit ah
c'est vrai il y a des bébés qui sont
morts en Palestine bah oui et pas
d'aujourd'hui et pas d'une semaine
depuis des années et là il se découvrent
le matin une passion pour la Palestine
c'est très bien tant mieux mais je
trouve ça je trouve ce trucs ce genre de
truc là il y a rien de mieux pour
diviser et je redis encore c'est la même
chose que choisir un camp c'est la même
chose que le tweet de Karim Benzema
c'est pareil quand il tweet sur Gaza
c'est très bien bravo à lui mais
j'aimerais bien qu'il tweete sur le
professeur j'aimerais bien qu'il twite
sur les supporters belges qui se sont
fait tuer les Suédois qui se sont fait
tuer j'aimerais bien qu'il disent c'est
pas tous les musulmans qui font ça ne
mets pas d'amalgame j'aimerais bien
qu'il fasse ça j'aimais bien qu'il twite
sur Gaza parce qu'il a une grosse
puissance et c'est en ça que je dis ça
vous me faites pas croire que c'est pas
fait pour diviser bien sûr que les gens
chez eux les momes chez eux quand il voi
le tweet de Benzema ils sont d'un côté
ou d'un autre et eux pareil pour eux
pareil pour eux 39 millions de vues 36
millions de vues vous allez pas me dire
que c'est il y a pas un problème après
vous pouvez dire c'est pas grave on
laisse mais moi je suis pas content
après les mecs qui découvrent la
Palestine avanttiier là c'est pas
avantiè le problème et Gill aussi le le
fait de vraiment légitimer le fait qu'il
y ait des gens qui choisissent un camp
et faire grandir ça c'est en fait euh
les prémisses d'une guerre civile par ex
arrêtez vous allez bientôt me dire que
je vais réclamer la guerre civile arrête
dis
fracture y a une fracture qui est réelle
ça on l'entend mais après tu as de choix
ou tu la regrettes ou tu tu l'applaudis
et toi tu l'appudis engagements passent
audessus d'un contrat cette phrase elle
est très belle pour moi mes valeurs
passent au-dessus de l'économie et d'un
salaire c'est magnifique ce qu'elle
dit pardonne parce que tu dis encore une
fois mes engagems passentessus d' contat
magif ce qu'elle dit je pose la question
de ses engagements quels sont ses
engagements ça veut dire que je pense
que F elle doit beaucoup embrouiller g
parce que siil croit ça fr dire quoi ça
veut dire raison
sa plusaime
bien voilà deux son les deux ça veut
dire qu' tout ça veut dire qu'elle blog
le Hamas avec les Palestiniens ça veut
dire qu'elle enembloue les Israéliens
avec leur gouvernement ça veut dire
qu'elle fait une sor de Glou pas sû
qu'il a 5 6 ans il y a 5 6 ans quand
excuse-moi Valéri quand ça cartonnait
vraiment les influenceurs il a 5 6 ans
je suis pas sûr qu'elle aurait pété son
contrat elle l'aurait laissé tranquille
elle aurait fermé sa gueule elle aurait
bissé les yeux je suis pas sûr là c'est
parce que ça part en sucette de tout
côtés mais je pense que c'est ça aussi
il y a un peu de aussi par c'est pas au
mois d'octobre qu'il fallait dire mes
engagements c'est pas au mois d'octobre
la guerre Israël palestinienne elle a
pas commencé au mois d'octobre là elle a
pas commencé en 2023 donc les
engagements c'est pas en 2023 les
convictions c'est pas en 20 profité elle
en a juste profité parce que ça ça
faisait un peu bien parce que faut
savoir que les personnalités chez
Magalie Berda ça fait des mois qu'elles
se bousculent pour sortir donc là en
plusag a pu
faireurs c'est comment le conflit
s'importe dans
la
pasid
pas par
dans par vous êtes
pay dans un instant rebondissement dans
l'affaire Stan Plaz n Témo exclusive
dans tes PMP exclusive de témoignages
dans un instant et on aura d'incroyables
révélations dans l'affaire Émile coup de
théâtre vous allez voir ça rebondit
Gilles Verdez Michel Marie sera avec
nous nous fera le le point vous allez
voir l'affaire mile rebondit ah oui là
ça avance ou ça avance je pense que on
arrive ou on arrive on arriveou à tout
de suite